يوميا تزور اكرام هذا المركز هنا تمضي
طفلتها التي تبلغ عامها الخامس قريبا
ساعات للتعلم
لكن اكرام وغيرها من اللاجئات السوريات لن
يتمكن من ادخال اطفالهن الى المدارس
العاديه
فعدد كبير من الاطفال السوريين ولاسباب
متعدده لا يملكون اوراقا ثبوتيه
اولاد خلقه عندهم شهاده الولاده من المشفى
من المختار بس مع ما بقدر انزل اعمل لهم
دفتر عالي ولا فيني هون داعي بدفتر عائله
اوراقك ولدتها ببيروت
يعني جمعيه ما انه بدي اقول لك مشفى او
شيء
سجلتوا لي اياها
سكرت المشفى لمسكره
اكثر من 200 طفل سوري يتلقون تعليمهم في
هذا المجمع الخشبي التابع لجمعيه بيون
30% منهم لا يملكون اوراقا ثبوتيه وهي
نسبه تعكس واقعا يعيش اطفال سوريون ولدوا
في لبنان ولان بيوند تعنى بمحاربه عماله
الاطفال لمست الجمعيه ازدياد نسب العماله
مع فقدان الهويه اول حاء هو حقه بالهويه
فبالتالي مستحيل نقبل انه هدول الاطفال
يبقوا بدون اهم حق من الحقوق لانه الاهل
بيقدروا يعملوا الكثير يعني بيقدروا على
القليله يسجلوا لحد ما توصل
يعني للمختار او بس يكون في شهاده ولاده
لهذا الولد ثاني شيء
البروسيس الدوله اللبنانيه سهلتها شوي
وخاصه انه لما قالت ما في داعي بقى
للاقامه
الدوله بعد عندها جهد لازم تعمله
اكثر المنظمات المجتمع الدولي لازم يعني
التمويل عندها
[موسيقى]
مفوضيه اللاجئين رات ان التسجيل الولادات
هو خطوه اساسيه للحصول على هويه ومع
الصعوبات التي يواجهها اللاجئون تسعى
الامم المتحده بالشراكه مع الحكومه
اللبنانيه الى تسهيل عمليه تسجيل الاطفال
كمواطنين السوريين بحسب المفوضيه سيكون
لبنان امام مجتمع من مكتومي القيد في حال
لم تتخذ المؤسسات الدوليه الاجراءات
اللازمه لمساعده اطفال اللاجئين في مواجهه
مستقبل غامض غنوه يتيم العربيه البقاع